mais d'abord le procès papon avec une
audience importante aujourd'hui à la
barre des témoins l'historien michel
bergès qui a passé des années aux côtés
des parties civiles avant de prendre le
parti de maurice papon aujourd'hui il a
présenté de nouveaux documents à
l'audience mais qui semble-t-il n'ont
pas convaincu sur place philippe denis
et pierre dick
jusqu'au dernier moment michel bergès à
réviser ces notes comme s'il voulait
soigneusement pesé chacun de ses mots ce
politologue est plongé depuis 15 ans
dans les archives de la sphère papon
longtemps aux côtés des accusateurs il a
ensuite coupé les ponts pour se
rapprocher de l'accusé mais comme il le
dira d'emblée à la barre je n'ai ni à
attaquer ni à défendre un camp il
tiendra cette conduite pendant 2h30 d'un
exposé très prudent devant un accusé
attentif michel bergès s'est contenté de
souligner les incertitudes du dossier et
de prodiguer des conseils à la cour pour
parvenir à la vérité
le chercheur a bien fourni quelques
documents qualifiés de pièces nouvelles
par le président mais aucun ne semble
contenir une de ces révélations
annoncées la foule de curieux plus
nombreuses aujourd'hui que d'habitude en
a été pour ses frais c'est un pétard
mouillé et c'est bien ce que je pensais
avant l'audience
j'en suis
j'en ai confirmation maintenant aucun
d'eux
anele moment
laisser supposer
l'instruction
et des fêtes de façon
ok ou de façon insuffisant michel bergès
s'en va la queue entre les jambes après
sans avoir rien apporté sinon
une
remarque révisionnistes sur la période
de l'occupation ce qui m'intéresse ce ne
sont pas des révélations c'est l'analyse
c'est la compréhension par la véritable
histoire bien
koné ce qui s'est passé qui connaît le
dosier comme personne vous êtes une
analyse
donc vous avez remarqué que maurice
papon est pratiquement absent bien sûr à
travers ses doutes michel bergès s'est
gardé d'accabler maurice papon mais il
ne l'a pas franchement défendue non plus
le sauvetage de certains juifs par
exemple que l'accusé revendiquent ils
auraient été faits dans une proportion
limitée
c'était du grappillage a même dit le
chercheur son témoignage avait été
annoncé comme un éventuel tournant du
procès il a été presque anodin